Vincent voulait s'apprête le 20 janvier
prochain à recevoir le don d'un des
reins de sa conjointe le don que Mélanie
a fait là c'est
inestimable j'ai des beaux gros reins en
santé
toute fonctionne à parfaite parfaitement
fait que c'est pour ça que je peux
donner mon rein à Vincent pour éviter de
contracter une maladie le couple doit
déjà être en isolement depuis la fin
décembre il sera en convalescence pour
au moins deux mois après l'opération
pour ces trois mois d'arrêt de travail
Madame Dupont on a droit qu'à 55% de son
salaire avec l'assurance emploi ce que
déplore le couple
de la vie c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
beaucoup là
de dédommagement dans la province les
travailleurs ont droit à deux journées
payées pour faire un don d'organes ou de
tissus transplant Québec peut offrir aux
donneurs une compensation allant jusqu'à
près de 6000 dollars mais en raison de
son salaire jugé trop élevé Madame
Dupont dit n'avoir droit qu'à 60$
supplémentaires par semaine
j'ai pas besoin de faire ça pour ma
santé ça va sauver énormément d'argent
ou gouvernement parce que les
traitements dialyse que je fais coûtent
environ 60 000 dollars par année tandis
qu'une greffe coûte à peu près 25000
dollars en Nouvelle-Zélande depuis 2017
les personnes qui donnent un organe de
leur vivant sont des dommages à 100%
pour leur perte de salaire engendré par
l'opération depuis les dons vivants ont
triplé ils représentent maintenant la
moitié des greffes on t'entend au Québec
on tort au Canada en attendant le couple
peut aussi compter sur plus de 7500
dollars qu'ils ont réussi à récolter
grâce à un site de dons en ligne était
énormément touché c'est à chaque fois
qu'on voit un don rentré on est surpris
c'est incroyable un comité d'experts a
également transmis au gouvernement du
Québec des recommandations suggérant des
augmentations substantielles des
compensations financières offertes au
donneur ici Louis Philippe Barcelon
Radio-Canada Québec